au nombre le président vénézuélien
nicolas maduro se dit prêt à discuter
avec son homologue américain si
nécessaire je suis prêt à discuter
respectueusement avec le président
donald trump dans un entretien publié
dimanche donald trump a ouvert la porte
à une rencontre entre les deux chefs
d'état avant de poser comme condition
une sortie effective du pouvoir
contrairement à la gauche radicale je
serai toujours contre le socialisme est
avec le peuple du venezuela
mon administration a toujours été du
côté de l'indépendance et de la liberté
et contre le régime oppressif de maduro
je ne rencontrerai maduro que pour
discuter d'une seule chose une sortie
pacifique du pouvoir
une invitation qui fait suite à une
attaque de son rival démocrate à la
présidence joe biden sur sa prétendue
admiration pour maduro trump eux parlent
du roman du venezuela mais il admire les
voyous et les dictateurs comme maduro la
réélection en 2018 de nicolás maduro a
toujours été rejetée par washington et
une cinquantaine d'autres pays préférant
reconnaître juan garrido comme président
légitime des sanctions financières sont
alors imposés par les états unis
sanctions jugées abusives par caracas
chaque fois que nous avons tenté de
procéder à un virement électronique
les transactions ont été rejetés ou
renvoyer sur nos comptes bancaires dans
le meilleur des cas des sanctions qui
empêcherait notamment le venezuela
d'honorer sa dette auprès de
l'organisation internationale
près de 22 millions de dollars sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires pour rétablir
son droit de vote
quant à gouaille d'eau les etats unis
lui ont demandé de mettre entre
parenthèses ses velléités
présidentielles dans l'attenté d'une
prochaine échéance électorale et ont
proposé au venezuela un nouveau cadre
pour une transition démocratique
une proposition rejetée par caracas
[Musique]